[Musica]
stasera
parleremo di futuro di futuro perché io
mi occupo di progettare per lo spazio è
l'obiettivo sarà per voi diventare una
specie multi planetaria quella che
vedete qui una luna non è vero purtroppo
ma chissà magari un giorno potrete
andare anche voi su quella vera
l'obiettivo infatti per diventare una
specie multi planetaria e l'accesso allo
spazio e una possibilità nuova che noi
adesso abbiamo se pensiamo alla storia
dell'esplorazione spaziale
ci ricordiamo dei grandi protagonisti ne
è costellata yuri gagarin john glenn
furono i primi agli inizi degli anni
sessanta a vedere la terra dall'orbita
jim lovell fece questa fotografia al
rais
la vigilia di natale del 68 e alla
missione apollo ott per la prima volta
l'umanità vide la terra dall orbita
lunare per la prima volta abbiamo visto
la terra come una bellissima biglia blu
circondata dal vuoto cosmico e ne
abbiamo capitoli intrinseca fragilità da
proteggere
l'anno scorso abbiamo celebrato i 50
anni dell'allunaggio
i due grandi protagonisti armstrong dei
green un piccolo passo per l'uomo un
grande passo per l'umanità
ora soleluna noi vogliamo
tornarci ma per restarci
se però davvero vogliamo ritornarci
dobbiamo anche ricordarci delle
centinaia di migliaia di persone che
hanno contribuito alle missioni apollo
scienziati astronauti tecnici ingegneri
tutti i volti nello stesso obiettivo per
la stessa avventura e tra questi grandi
protagoniste femminili come catherine
johnson ei filati volte sono soltanto
due quelle che vi cito stasera ma sono
molti di più grazie a loro è stato
possibile fare ritornare astronauti a
terra ed ora ci troviamo qui sulla
international space station che
quest'anno compie vent'anni di attività
sono tantissime dell'unica architettura
che abbiamo oggi nello spazio 221 space
work 239 individui tra astronauti
specialisti di missione e bene 2.700
progetti in orbita sviluppati da 108
paesi diversi da tutto il mondo
questa è una grandissima impresa di
collaborazione internazionale e devo
prendere esempio da questa avventura
ma se questo è stato possibile
c'è anche un motivo ben preciso che è
cambiato il paradigma oggi l'agenzia
spaziale internazionale come la nasa ed
esa sono volte ad aprire l'accesso allo
spazio ed è il motivo per il quale
bandiscono concorsi di idee aperti a
tutte scuole università centri di
ricerca per permettere a chiunque di
portare il proprio tassello di
creatività innovazione all'interno del
grande puzzle dell'esplorazione spaziale
e un'occasione unica e nel mio piccolo
ho partecipato a questi concorsi de così
che è nato il mio percorso l mighty
partecipando intime multidisciplinari
questi sono
oggetti estremamente complessi che
richiedono una quantità di conoscenza
che è inimmaginabile e quindi è per
questo che i gruppi di lavoro sono
multidisciplinari si lavora sempre
intime the necessari la sinergia
progettuale che ognuno di noi ha fatto
lo sforzo di uscire un po dalla propria
zona di comfort e disciplinare dal
proprio guscio per estendere la propria
conoscenza verso l'altro ed è stata
un'esperienza interessante perché grazie
a questo abbiamo progettato dei veri e
propri gate di portali per
l'esplorazione questo è il primo gate
l'orbita terrestre
questo nostro primo progetto era nato da
un concorso di idee bandito dalla nasa
con l'idea di riutilizzare i moduli di
l'international space station
però abbiamo detto al momento
l'international space station è una casa
laboratorio ma cosa accadrebbe se la
facessimo diventare anche una struttura
ricettiva per ospitare turisti nello
spazio
ditemi che cosa vorreste vedere una
volta in orbita la terra penso di sì
un'esperienza unica che ogni astronauta
ricorda con grande emozione
loro hanno un modulo cupola vetrato che
permetta loro una finestra sul mondo ed
è installato il nodo 3 e l'international
space station ne abbiamo pensato di
aggregare questo modulo con tutta una
serie di camere per i turisti spaziali
che una volta pressurizzate offrivano
una finestra sul mondo
poi ci siamo chiesti quale altra grande
caratteristica offre lo spazio è
ovviamente la microgravità poter
fluttuare nello spazio come il mondo
sottomarino
ed è questa analogia che con il
ricercatore del responsivo in varone
salmi the lab
abbiamo portato avanti un progetto
partendo spunti ispirandoci ai
cavallucci marini la loro capacità di
navigare sott'acqua con la loro coda e
utilizzarla anche come strumento
prensile diventa assolutamente una
caratteristica fondamentale per
fluttuare in microgravità
questo progetto è un salto robot
indossabile come se fosse un
esoscheletro a 36 camere d'aria che
gonfiandosi sgonfiandosi permettono di
ottenere diverse configurazioni che
vanno a cambiare il posizionamento
bilanciamento del corpo di chi li
indossa
sarebbe fantastico poterlo ovviamente
portare sulla international space
station al momento ci siamo accontentati
di testarla su un volo parabolico con lo
space exploration initiatives con il
quale abbiamo effettuato una ventina di
parabole con diversi tipi di gravità
ridotta in questo video potete vedere la
mia prima però vuole microgravità
e stata un'esperienza unica bellissima
la ricordo con immensa emozione gioia ed
è motivo per il quale con la stessa
emozione sono qui di fronte a questa
sera indossando la stessa tuta non ho
con me l'esoscheletro è vero non
funzionerebbe con la gravità ma in
microgravità come potete vedere dove sta
l'emozione iniziale
se poi siamo riusciti a capire come
ottenere quel bilanciamento del corpo
utilizzando questo sistema robotico e
penso spero che un giorno potrebbe
indossarla anche voi gate 2 la luna per
questa destinazione noi abbiamo pensato
a un villaggio è un progetto che però
richiede un approccio diverso perché
sulla luna noi non possiamo mandare
rifornimenti soltanto dell'aterno e
dovremo essere in grado di integrare
nostri architetture nostre
infrastrutture in loco
utilizzando un materiale locale abbiamo
iniziato quindi a studiare dovere i
depositi di ghiaccio ad esempio
e dov'erano tutta una serie di risorse
utili per costruire infrastrutture il
polo sud della luna e ricco di ghiaccio
e per il nostro progetto abbiamo
selezionato un cratere lo sceglie
concrete perché una posizione strategica
prima di tutto ci permette di vedere la
terra costantemente in secondo abbiamo
la possibilità di essere alimentati
dall'energia solare utile per alimentare
energeticamente l'habitat questo è
un'immagine dall'alto del villaggio come
vedete servono tantissimi moduli se ora
gli straniati dall'environment lunare
guardando questa foto sembra quasi il
notturno di un villaggio di montagna con
tutte le sue casette
ed è proprio così perché ogni i moduli
in realtà come se fosse una piccola
casetta all'interno del quale possiamo
ospitare quattro astronauti
ovviamente i moduli in questo caso
vengono spediti dalla terra alla luna
quasi completi dovranno poi essere
pressurizzati e integrati con uno
schermo di regolite che è il terreno
lunare che viene stampata in 3d e
costituisce un ottimo materiale per
proteggere gli umani all'interno di
questa struttura dalle micro meteoriti e
dalle radiazioni cosmiche
questo progetto è una partnership con
l'agenzia spaziale europea
lo studio architettura s and the mighty
ed una partnership che deve essere presa
credo ad esempio per i futuri progetti
nello spazio considerato anche il fatto
che al suo interno contiene delle
risorse inimmaginabili degli astronauti
abbiamo infatti collaborato con jeffrey
kaufmann jr
che ci hanno aiutato a progettare gli
interni cosa e non banale
pensate a vivere in isolamento in un
luogo confinato piccolo dove tutti gli
spazi sono condivisi e dedicarvi una
storia cuccetta come vostra stanza
privata è ben difficile sapete e quindi
saper progettare ovviamente minimizzando
gli spazi volume la massa perché
possiamo portare ben poca massa sulla
luna ed è veramente una sfida che grazie
agli astronauti siamo riusciti a
risolvere il terzo gate e marte una meta
lontana da raggiungere che però ci ha
offerto molti spunti di riflessione per
progettare su marte infatti abbiamo
pensato a una visione a lungo termine
2050 è una città i 10.000 abitanti
anche qui in questo caso dobbiamo
adottare delle strategie per costruire
su marte non possiamo portarci tutto
dalla terra ed è così che è nata l'idea
di un progetto che in qualche modo
prende spunto della natura in questo
caso le sequoie millenarie della red
bull forest californiana questo
algoritmo consente di progettare una
città sulla superficie del cratere
l'elise un monster pression estraendone
il ghiaccio sotterraneo ed utilizzarlo
come linfa vitale per le biosfere che
ospitano la vita ogni albero di questa
foresta e interconnesse più livelli sia
in superficie che nel sottosuolo
le radici sono state modellate
all'analogia dei ritmi delle piante e
scavando le riusciamo a mostrare il
ghiaccio necessario che verrà veicolato
nel sistema di rame per creare quello
schermo delle radiazioni cosmiche
mantenendo la trasparenza potendo quindi
vedere all'esterno
quella che vedete sono tutte possibili
configurazioni di rami ogni albero è
diverso dall'altro esattamente come in
natura
abbiamo poi cercato di capire come poter
costruire
questa struttura senza l'aiuto l'ausilio
degli uomini semplicemente in modo
autonomo e robotico e seppur in piccola
scala ne stiamo dimostrando la
potenzialità
abbiamo poi dovuto risolvere il problema
del cibo come andremo ad alimentare i
futuri abitanti di marte una missione su
marte dura anni e in questo progetto
abbiamo dovuto pensare come alimentare
quattro astronauti per 600 giorni che la
durata minima di permanenza sul pianeta
rosso è un progetto nato in
collaborazione tra i mighty e l'alta
scuola politecnica
abbiamo voluto integrare a complemento
del progetto del mar size dawn della
nasa che un modulo abitativo per quattro
astronauti una componente legato a una
produzione di cibo una serra idroponica
che utilizza anche la gravità ridotta
come risorse in quanto le piante
scorrono su una spirale l'intero modulo
verrà mandato sul su marte praticamente
già quasi completo però dovrà essere
mandato due anni prima che arrivino gli
umani modo tale da pressurizzato ed a
creare lo shield quindi la schermatura
necessaria le radiazioni cosmiche
anche qui il materiale è l'acqua come
vedete all'interno abbiamo realizzato
degli spazi che non sono soltanto ad uso
produttivo ma servono anche per ricreare
quel contatto privilegiato che abbiamo
per natura qui sulla terra
abbiamo anche quindi delle spirali per
gli umani delle passerelle di salite e
discese che consentono di percorrere una
camminata nel verde
sembra banale ma non lo è per un
astronauta e cosa accade quando invece
non abbiamo la possibilità di avere
effettivamente delle piante
nasce quindi l'idea di un portale un
portale multisensoriale in grado di
ricreare quella connessione con la
natura quella sinergia che noi abbiamo
col nostro pianeta quel bisogno di
riconnetterci e il deed march living off
salvatori portal è un progetto che nasce
per poter navigare in tempo reale la
riserva di teague march in massachusetts
che era stata preliminarmente
sensorizzati dal responsive ironman
selmi gara ed ecco qui una struttura a
uovo non mi ricordo una placenta materna
il materiale nuovo che abbiamo
realizzato e composto di carta
thailandese seta ed è plasmato con
questa doppia curvatura per creare delle
pareti traslucide ma protettive che
avvolgono il visitatore in queste
immagini il collaudo in un'esibizione il
mio professore daughters paradiso stiamo
testando quest'esperimento di immersione
ora come vedete il mio percorso
la spesa architects è davvero da
outsider non sono pilota non sono un
astronauta
non ancora
e non ho un training specifico però sto
cercando di portare il mio cappello di
creatività all'interno del grande puzzle
dell'esplorazione spaziale
perché il mio obiettivo è quello di
diventare una specie multi planetaria
ed ora invito voi ad accettare questa
sfida farne parte
perché riguarda il nostro futuro ed e
dove passeremo il resto dei nostri
giorni
grazie
[Applauso]